it's a smart money smart kids theme our
my daughter Rachel Cruz and I have
written a book by the same name we're
taking your questions and comments
talking about kids and money how to
raise money smart kids this our Jill is
in Sacramento hi Jill welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hi Dave hi Rachel hey
how are you doing great how can we help
hi I'm a single mom and I have a 13 year
old and my son I've been raising them on
my own since he was about three years
old and my question is about not I give
him a commission like you guys talked
about but my question is about the money
that he gets from his dad's side of the
family because they will send him money
sometimes I don't even know that he gets
it he comes in the mail and he gets it
before I get home or they'll just buy
him expensive things and I'm not sure
how to instill in him the saving of that
money if it doesn't come from me I'm not
really sure how to control that part of
it so just wondering if you had any
advice for that on you know sources of
income that he gets from places other
than myself because I'm having a hard
time trying to get him to save it you
know sure well there's several things
going on number one you have a 13 year
old boy and in that in and of itself is
a handful and that's just you know in
and of itself and on top of that as a
single mom he's going through trying to
assert his manhood in a way that is
appropriate and still be respectful to
his mom he doesn't know how to do that
and so he's going to have to have some
training from you that he can be a man
and still be respectful for his mom
especially especially respectful for his
mom is the sign of his manhood but
that's part of the process here because
here's the deal I'm an old school dad so
some people won't agree with this and I
don't really care whether they agree
with it or not as far as I'm concerned
in your household money that comes to
your household is under your control and
the fact that he goes to mail box gets
money out and doesn't tell you about it
is unacceptable that is like lying okay
just like him lying to you about his
grades that's like him lying to you
about something else and so here's the
agreement I'm going to have with the
young man if he wants to live okay the
agreement is going to be that I am your
mom I love you deeply and I'm going to
guide you in the proper handling of
money any money that comes to you is
under my control because you are under
my control
I have sole custody of you you are under
my control and I'm not going to steal
your money I'm not going to use your
money for my uses but you are going to
handle any money that comes to you in a
way that is good for you and that is my
decision because I'm the parent and so
all money goes on top of the table
regardless of where it comes from and we
have a healthy discussion about properly
spending and enjoying some of it about
properly saving some of it and about
properly giving some of it and I don't
care where the money came from I don't
care if you worked for it I don't care
if your mother your ex mother-in-law
sends it to him
I don't care if where if he wins the
lotto he's 13 and you're the mom you're
in control
that makes a lot of sense and it goes
and but now this is all for his good I'm
not taking advantage of him and that's
because I'm not trying to you know if
one of them says well she just take his
money and he I don't give a rip if you
don't want to send money over here you
don't like the way it's handled when it
comes in this household then don't send
money over here and that's your message
to these people who are violating your
boundaries because you know they're
trying to be subversive yeah it's
sabotaging yeah it's I feel guilt from
no I mean he doesn't see them very often
at all you can't spend your way out of
guilt that's a message you need to get
to him but I don't mind them sending
money but they need to understand that
when the money comes in that the head of
this household is in charge of this
money yeah boom just like that hammer
down well that sounds like something
that can definitely happen
then you put your arm around the young
man and say I am here to grow you into a
young man and men are givers and men are
savers and men are wise spenders do the
same thing with a young woman a woman a
proper woman that is emotionally mature
this is what I'm my job is to grow you
into this and you're not always going to
like it you're not always going to agree
with me it doesn't matter I'm the parent
and that means I'm right I'm in charge
and does that make sense that sounds
very old-school doesn't it it's it makes
a lot of sense I as a matter of fact I
am I actually am a personal finance high
school teacher okay and I use your
curriculum in my class all the time and
but this one had me stumped I was you
know I well but let me tell you let me
tell you where it's a great call and a
great question because it came up at our
house one time one of our kids had a job
and they were making money and they came
in they said it's my money and I said no
no I meant you're confused I own you and
I own the money you don't even have a
life I own you so now let's start there
you got confused like you had some power
you're 14 give me a break you have no
power and I'm going to own you for your
own good I'm not trying to take you and
I can do anything inappropriate but you
are going to do things in such a way
that are beneficial to you and at 14 you
don't have all the tools yet to make
that decision and so I'm your dad we're
going to guide this we're going to talk
it out together as long as you can talk
and when you quit being able to talk and
you want to act like a four-year-old
then I'll treat you like a four-year-old
so will do however you want to play this
but we're going to play it out for your
good and me maintaining my parental
rights in this household and that's
where we're coming from that sound like
it would have happened at our house
sounds about right you just heard it
America huh that's about it well I mean
it you know yeah it wasn't it and it's
not a mean thing you don't want we're
not trying to it's not up we're not on a
power trip or something it's not
bullying no and like we said in the
first segment too there's a balance too
and there are gonna be times your kids
are going to make mistakes with money
and that's okay you know you want to
learn you want them to fail and learn
mistakes but at the same time you do
want that control in a sense over them
to still guide them and shape them so
there is a balance to it all but overall
her situation especially you know is a
little extreme of
getting these checks in the mail you
have to be the parent and step in and
props to her I mean as a single mom like
she I mean that's that's a very tiring
tiring job that she has and she's doing
a great job with it and so I think just
that extra step I think we'll fix we'll
fix the situation so no I agree with
your advice
I had a counseling session one time with
a parent whose kid um was unbelievably
talented let's just leave it at that and
the kid was making serious Bank like
Hollywood type kid situation likes child
actor type situation and the kids making
this serious money and all of a sudden
this 15 year old is running the whole
house because she's making all this
money and you know what you either stop
that then or the child grows up to be
the product of being a child actor or
child star or child whatever and they
you know don't turn out well for the
ones whose parents quit parenting
because the child became financially
successful they lost their right to
parent somehow in their own mind because
the child became financially successful
and that's an extreme version of what
that particular lady there is facing
what jill is facing
you